you know something I'm really opposed to  how Pokemon is you got to think about it  you got this this this creature and  they're intelligent because they can  talk right so they could talk they have  conversation they have souls you going  to feel you see these dudes minding  their business living their life you  grab them  no yeah  I got it I got a worse  hold up hold up it's even worse than  that what they've done in this game in  Pokemon Scarlet is they have scenarios  where you'll see like the first form  like five or six around the last form so  pretty much there's insinuating this is  the the mom these are the kids you could  just run up to be like your kids are  mine  you judging them like